je remercie je voudrais commencer par
une chose qui me paraît une chose très
importante puisqu'on parle de sciences
humaines et sociales et de transfèrement
globalement je sais que dans ces
enceintes on n'aime pas trop qu'on dit
ça mais sur le plan de la popularité
serait probablement dû nous nous
expliquer comment gérer les crises
sanitaires
les français aiment d'abord les
personnels de soin ensuite les
chercheurs ce qu'ils aiment le moins de
tous ces journalistes les hommes
politiques et donc quand un sujet de
santé est pris je m'excuse vous dire ça
mais c'est la vérité
non mais en fait on le sait on le sait
bien quand un sujet de santé est pris
est pris en otage par les politiques
pour le gérer c'est une catastrophe il
vaut mieux nous laisser faire ça parce
que les gens plus confiance je crois que
c'est un point important cette confiance
là il faut s'en méfier parce que l on a
un risque de décrédibiliser de notre de
notre métier parce qu'on passe d'une
époque scientiste dans lequel on croyait
on nous pourrons nous a cru tout
puissant m'a remplacé les dieux est en
réalité nous sommes dans une période où
cette cette croyance qui est partagé par
un certain nombre de scientifiques qui
pensent que ce qu'il croit à un moment
est une vérité établie nous amène à voir
le public constaté que nous sommes
arrogants parce que nous nous trompons
souvent et donc moi je suis très je suis
en désaccord mais comme souvent avec un
certain nombre de présentation ici
voyais tous les gens qui nous disent qui
va se passer en 2020 et 2050 sont c'est
comme mon voisin de strada mussy
laissait prévoir des choses que personne
ne peut prévoir
on ne sait pas donc toutes
interrogations sur l'avenir doit
commencer par on ne sait pas mais si les
choses se passent comme elles se sont
passées dans le passé la projection
donne ça mais la vie est pleine de
surprises et d'événements chaotique que
nous ne pouvons pas prévoir et sa mine
notre crédibilité qu'un certain nombre
de scientifiques croient pouvoir prédire
l'avenir et les catastrophes et ensuite
l'absence de réalisation de ces
prédictions nous mine sans arrêt et
minera notre crédibilité à terre alors
les infections dans le monde et les
problèmes majeurs c'est plus de 30 % 30
% c'est les infections aiguës mais c'est
au moins 30% les trois grands sida
tuberculose paludisme un trou on promet
aux gens des vaccins pour ça qu'ils
marcheront il y en a toujours pas c'est
pas une faute d'argent
on a mis des milliards là dessus c'est
qu'il ya un trou de connaissances nous
sommes ignorants dhr ça nous ne savons
pas comment on fait les vaccins pour les
maladies pour lequel qui ne sont pas
immunisés ans tu es un trou de
connaissances deuxièmement les
infections digestives et des infections
respiratoires qui sont les plus communes
et les plus grands tueurs à la surface
de la terre
les infections prévenus par les
vaccinations qui sont en train de tout
rebond d'hier les cancers infectieux
canton d'oubli qui sont affectueux à peu
près 25 % au moins des cancers sont
d'origine infectieuse et puis les
infections émergentes qui naissent de
trois aspects d'une part des outils
nouveaux qui compte notre ignorance une
partie de notre ignorance est à peu près
90% 80 à 90 % de ce que nous connaissons
maintenant à moins de 20 ans on va le
voir
deuxièmement les changements dans notre
environnement les rencontres les
maladies infectieuses sait jamais que le
délit libres de notre écosystème est
donc en changeant de niche en changeant
d'écosystèmes et bien on est exposé à de
nouveaux risques et de nouveaux microbes
et l'existence de nouveaux organismes et
comme comme ça a été dit par manuguerra
surtout surtout les nouveaux organismes
c'est les bactéries résistantes et les
virus à arn c'est ça majoritairement la
diapositive suivante
voyez le nombre de bactéries découverte
depuis ces dernières années on est passé
de 1800 en 1981 actuellement on est à
14000 bactérie identifiée répertoriés et
donc vous voyez cette augmentation est
ondes au tout début il faut vous
imaginer qu'il y à 3 millions d'insectes
d'espèces d'insectes connu et nous
n'avons 14000 bactéries y apprendre bien
plus grande diversité de bactéries que
la fête
nous on s'est beaucoup battu là dedans
on essaie d'en prendre une proportion
non négligeable et je veux dire que tout
ça a été possible simplement c'est un
vrai message que je vous faire passer
parce que dans les chu et grâce au
financement du pratique de 2,2 du
ministère de la santé
nous avons pu constituer ce alors que ça
n'était pas une priorité organisée au
niveau national ça n'était pas possible
nationalement s'il n'y avait pas eu les
chu pour faire cela il n'y aurait pas de
maladies infectieuses dans ce pays c'est
la même chose sur les génomes
moi mon premier séquenceur cp hrc qui la
paient ceni l'inserm du cnrs pour
chercher et vous voyez là aussi
l'explosion de la connaissance des
génomes et de demain
fera des génomes en 24 heures sur les
bactéries émergentes mais vous voyez sur
la diapositive de droite là la
proportion de l'incompréhension totale
du monde que nous avons c'est à dire que
quand on sait qu'en ce tout ce qu'il ya
dans notre environnement
eh bien il ya 70% des séquences
génétiques dont on ne sait pas si elles
sont virales si elles sont bactérienne
ou si elles appartiennent à des
occasions
donc c'est une ignorance complète de
akwa raccrocher 70% de l'expression du
vivant nous est totalement inconnue et
c'est un des défis de l'avenir
quand on voit ça on doit prendre
conscience tout de suite que à chaque
fois qu'on nous pose une question aux
douaniers l'attendait je ne sais pas
l'état des connaissances et ça mais je
sais que déjà demain il sera différent
parce que dans cette période l'évolution
de la connaissance et radicale et elle
nécessite des changements de de pensée
de paradigme la diapositive suivante
en même temps nous sommes ignorants mais
on n'est pas tous au même degré
d'ignorance
il y en a qui sont ignorants parce qu'en
plus ils ne lisent pas ils ne savent pas
ce qui s'est passé
donc il y en a qui sont ignorants parce
que personne ne sait et d'autres qui
sont ignorants parce qu'ils ne savent
pas je vais vous dire premièrement la
folie de la grippe espagnole
en réalité la grippe espagnole a tué et
85 à 90% des gens qui sont morts sont
morts d'infection bactérienne
on le savait au début de 2009 et donc
c'est intéressant
la bonne pratique des antibiotiques que
j'ai appris avec mon ami bricaire qui
était on donne pas d'antibiotiques à la
grippe est pas vrai c'est à dire que en
réalité le fait de donner des
antibiotiques aux gens qui ont 48 heures
de grippe est la meilleure sauvegarde
pour empêcher les gens de mourir
et d'ailleurs la proportion des gens qui
meurent de grippe diminuer la proportion
de ceux qui meurent de surinfection
bactérienne diminue depuis qu'on a les
antibiotiques
donc vous voyez un modèle massive qu'on
a tous enseigné qu'il faut dont on s'est
rendu compte par l'analyste par la
connaissance
voyez donc il y aura plus de grippe
espagnole parce qu'on a des
antibiotiques et parce que 50% moore et
d'infections à pneumocoque et qu'on a du
vaccin pour prévenir le monocoque on le
savait c'est et publié par klugman en
2006 il décrivait dans un papier dans le
journal nature
le vaccin antipneumococcique protège
contre la grippe
c'était écrit on le savait mais c'est un
de nos problèmes c'est que les
virologues ne lis
la bactériologie la bactériose les
bactériologiste ne lisent pas la
virologie et que donc si vous prenez
vous mettez grippe et que vous mettez ça
comme mots clés dans le tout les
meilleurs journaux du monde pendant dix
ans il y en a peint sur lequel il ya
marqué grippé pneumocoque alors que
c'est le pneumocoque qui tu n'as donc
c'est simplement de l'aveuglément le
deuxième aveuglement c'est la folie de
la grippe aviaire attendait toutes les
maladies infectieuses émergentes
commencent toujours par les formes les
plus graves et qui sont toujours détecté
parce que le personnel de santé malade
c'est comme ça qu on les détecte quand
un personnel de santé moeurs de la même
maladie qu'un malade qu'il a reçus dans
l'hôpital c'est comme ça qu'on découvre
les maladies ça veut pas dire qu'elles
sont plus mortelle on est en train de
voir dans la grippe aviaire sur lequel
tout le monde fantasme qu'en réalité
c'est plein de formes asymptomatiques
il ya des gens qui sont au contact des
poules sur les anticorps contre la h1n1
et qui ont pas fait la maladie elle
n'est pas plus mortelle que les autres
quant à l'image du furet et qui est
devenue maintenant le grand prédicteur
de ce qui va être la transmissibilité
si vous avez déjà vu comment se transmet
la grippe entre les humains c'est-à-dire
essentiellement par les mains suit vous
expliquer comment le furet et peut
devenir un modèle de transmission de la
grippe c'est que manifestement on voit
pas les mêmes choses c'est pas vrai la
prédiction par le furet c'est pas vrai
c'est la prédiction chez le furet s'est
passé ni supérieur ni inférieure à la
prédiction qu'on voit chez le ch être la
folie de l'ape du bioterrorisme
j'ai été au milieu j'ai transformé le
rapport qu'on me demandait faire au
ministère de la santé en quelque chose
sur les maladies infectieuses émergentes
parce que je ne voulais pas parler
simplement d'une crise dont je voyais
bien une partie des tenants et des
aboutissants en particulier en attaque
l'index oxydation que nous faisait les
services américains
en réalité le bioterrorisme microbien il
n'ya eu depuis quarante ans que deux
exemples 1 c'est l'armée russe qui l'a
développé dans un laboratoire p3 à
canning d'orgue du charbon et qui a
laissé s'envoler un nuage de charbon qui
a tué au moins 100 personnes de sa
propre population s'est tiré dans le
pied deuxièmement c'est les américains
dans le laboratoire de fortes des tricks
ont recruté un scientifique y avait un
très lourd passé psychiatrique était fou
en pratique qui travaillait tout seul
qui a militarisé les choses qui est
ressorti de fort detrick avec deux ports
de charbon dans les poches et qui a
envoyé sa des hommes politiques et des
journalistes qui a fait un foin et qui
fait que l'ensemble des pays qui
travaillent sur les bactéries un peu
difficiles sont empoisonnés parce que
les américains ont été incapables de
errer dans leurs armes et des armes pour
mettez au point e même et qui n'en tue
et leurs populations et à partir de ça
on peut plus travailler sur la peste on
peut plus travailler sur la tularémie on
peut plus travailler sur des maladies
qui tuent vraiment les hommes
parce que tout ce fantasme a pris toute
la société autour du bioterrorisme qui
n'a jamais été que de la très mauvaise
gestion des deux plus grande armée du
monde
je vous signale d'ailleurs que c'est les
mêmes armes et qui ont dix russes de la
variole qui est la chose la plus
dangereuse du monde
ça devrait amener à des réflexions sur
la destruction des souches quatrièmement
une chose qui a pendant longtemps
inhiber le développement des maladies
infectieuses moi je me souviens de
lazard me disant on va pas faire les
maladies infectieuses à l'inserm
puisqu'ils à l'institut pasteur qui s'en
occupe l'institut pasteur entre temps
est devenu un institut essentiellement
concerné par la recherche fondamentale
et la recherche le soin épidémiologie le
diagnostic diagnostic a été vendu à
serbe à l'épidémiologie à petit à petit
disparu le transfert a été vendu à bio
rad et la situation est devenue un
institut essentiellement de recherche
fondamentale qui se réouvre c'est très
bien sur les maladies infectieuses mais
il faut pas croire que les problèmes du
pays vont être gérés par l'image que
vous avez de l'institut pasteur il ya 50
ans parce que c'est tout gt gt étudiants
c'est plus même c'est la recherche
fondamentale qui absorbe 90% de
l'énergie de l'institut pasteur
ça ne vous fera pas la santé la santé
c'est les sièges d'accord il ya une
discordance entre observation aux
chiffres nationaux moi si vous voulez
mon avis la maladie prioritaires
émergentes dans ce pays c'est les
septicémies nosocomiales j'ai estimé que
ça peut tuer douze mille personnes par
an les lyonnais avec qui on travaille
pense qu on a 24 mille morts par an les
anglais disent il ya dix mille morts
simplement par les septicémies à
staphylocoque doré
je m'excuse c'est plus important pour
l'instant que sarce mais simplement on
le regarde pas je ne sais pas pourquoi
ça n'existe pas les populations de voir
qu'on meurt de bactériémie à l'hôpital
alors qu'on pourrait pas en il ya des
mesures pour pouvoir lutter contre ça
qu'ils ont été mises en place sur des
sites pilotes aux états unis qui
permettent de réduire de 30% cette
mortalité par des mesures simples ça
c'est un élément essentiel c'est de
l'observation mais c'est sûr que
l'observation que nous faisons comparé à
l'observation de la nbs dans le même
tant les mbs noté sur la même période
qui avait 340 membres et nous on pensait
qu'il y avait rien qu'à marseille une
surmortalité 200 personnes ça veut dire
qu'on parle pas de la même chose et donc
il ya des moyens d'observation pas
seulement en afrique il faut regarder en
france de quoi les jeûneurs ce qui est
une chose très importante
enfin pourquoi c'est parce que la veille
sanitaire est de nature bio statistique
c'est pas les médecins santé publique
qui font la veille sanitaire c'est la
biostatistique ça c'est la leçon du cdc
aux états unis c'est fait par des péages
dit de biostatistiques on manie des
chiffres des données massives
je vous rappelle simplement que en 1976
la maladie du légionnaire a été trouvée
parce qu'il y avait une surmortalité des
hommes de plus de 50 ans pendant deux
semaines à philadelphie que ça a été vue
sans qu'un seul médecin a vu ses des
statistiques c'est de la comparaison par
rapport à la moyenne statistique
c'est comme ça qu'on découvre les
pathogènes émergents la diapositive
suivante
donc l'état doit se baser sur une base
doit s'appuyer sur une base scientifique
élargie et rapide pour intégrer les
données nouvelles qui se multiplient là
on est à l'âge des analyses massive tout
est répertorié dans les hôpitaux les
pires il ya maintenant trois programmes
de micro biologiques qui circulent dans
tous les hôpitaux il faut utiliser et
avoir des méthodes d'analysé massif
c'est un des points clés de l'avenir il
faut détecter les événements anormaux il
faut analyser les signaux on a besoin de
ça beaucoup plus que de réseaux un des
problèmes que nous avons ses clients
devaient s est venue du réseau national
de santé publique qui était un réseau de
médecins
maintenant ce dont nous avons besoin
c'est d' analyse massive de données
deuxièmement il faut développer sur la
veille sur les syndromes la veille sur
les syndromes c'est non médical
actuellement si vous voulez savoir si le
début d'une épidémie de gastro-entérite
a été étudié le premier signe c'est vous
tapez gastro entérite sur google si vous
avez une augmentation massive du nombre
d'interrogations dans le domaine où vous
êtes c'est le premier tous les signaux
le deuxième c'est l'absentéisme des
femmes jeunes parce qu'elles gardent
leurs gosses comme une gastro entérite
le troisième c'est la consommation
d'anti diarrhéiques dans les pharmacies
enfin c'est seulement les médecins qui
disent tiens j'ai vu trois cas de gastro
entérite nationale donc il faut changer
la nature de la veille des signaux il ya
une restructuration de la recherche
il faut mettre à la disposition tous les
investigateurs les données de mise à
jour
moi j'avais dit jean françois mattei en
2002 son cabinet avait apprécié plus ou
moins ce que tu risques le plus
et que personne ne sait quand on meurt
dans ce pays ce que je vous disais voyez
en 76 aux états unis en 2002 il y en
avait pas le début de tout ça et je lui
écris c'est une démo recommandations de
mon rapport je me souviens plus la 73 et
vous savez ce qui s'est passé en 2003 en
2003 quand il ya eu l'explosion de la
canicule
je les appelais disant écoute tu es sûr
qu'il ya pas de problème est-ce que je
peux aider je venais finir ma mission au
ministère il m'a dit non donc je me suis
tourné vers la direction générale de la
santé que l'indicé des bêtises après
août 2000 prend c'est à dire que les
services de l'état étaient incapables et
à la fin les statistiques ont été faites
par les croque-morts c'est croque mort
qu'on dit écoutez on est en rupture de
cercueils au milieu du mois d'août a pas
donc c'est ça l'état de la veille et moi
j'ai demandé pour savoir j'ai une
hypothèse que je veux vérifier je pense
que h1n1 a sauvé deux à trois mille vies
en france parce que elle a inhibé pour
des raisons absolument incompréhensible
les autres circulation de la grippe et
qu'elle s'est arrêtée en décembre je
vérifier ça donc je voudrais avoir les
données du pays bien pour l'instant peut
pas les avoir et pour les avoir il faut
que je paye 30000 euros pour pouvoir
voir savoir qui est mort dans ce pays ou
dans les domaines qui sont collectés par
le pays d'envoyer l'accès aux données
brutes c'est un des éléments essentiels
de la surveillance et il faut les
mutualiser et enfin il est nécessaire
d'investir dans des noeuds
technologiques multiples de type ia chu
mais pas qu'à marseille
la diapositive suivante il faut donner
la diapositive suivante et enfin on a
des organisations un centralisme un
isolement avoir créé liên vs à
saint-maurice sens en microbiologie 100
malades sans rechercher sans
universitaire c'est une faute
il faudra bien à un moment réfléchi il
faut mettre les gens ensemble sinon
créer des cultures qui sont non
seulement séparés mais qui deviennent
antagonistes les uns et les autres se
sentent en compétition se dispute ne
pense plus pareil c'est pas la peine de
faire des réunions si les instituts sont
complètement isolés il faut les
regrouper il faut faire des noeuds dans
lequel on met les gens ensemble et qui
travaille ensemble on a détruit la
recherche en malines tropicales et des
voyages c'est quelque chose qui est plus
de cent ans on a des larmes et d'un coup
a décidé ce qui était la plus grande
source de médecins de médecine tropicale
a décidé de tout déplacer à brétigny et
donc on fait maintenant la médecine
tropicale et des voyages brétigny et à
peu près tous les gens qui étaient
responsables de ça je regrette beaucoup
parce que j'avais beaucoup aidé la
formation scientifique
avec un accord avec l'armée ont tous
démissionné on a détruit la base de sa
les centres nationaux de référence se
reproduisent à l'infini sans jamais
faire face est-ce qu'en france on a
besoin d'un centre national de référence
spécialiste de la peste du charbon
garage ou est-ce qu'il faut avoir des
centres de connaissances ça n'a pas de
sens par rapport à des priorités de
santé publique
les comités je m'excuse de dire ça voyez
vous ne faites revenir à paris pour
parler cinq minutes mais dans le fait
perdre plus d'une journée pour ça donc
je le ferai une fois je vais pas faire
que ça parce que je dois travailler de
temps en temps donc les comités sont
surtout composées doazit food parisien
parfois les deux pour des raisons
mécaniques je m'excuse ce pays pourrait
aussi un peu se moderniser et commencé à
faire des vidéoconférences qui nous
oblige pas à perdre une journée pour
venir discuter avec pendant une demi
heure il faut un peu se moderniser tout
peut pas se passer dans une salle de
réunion au ministère
donc ça aux états unis on fait ça depuis
longtemps je m'excuse parfois n'importe
qui avec un ordinateur est capable de
faire une visioconférence il faut
s'arrêter de nous faire venir pour nous
pour pour passer une journée et demie
sinon vous n'aurez pas enfin vous aurez
les experts que vous aurez mais en tout
cas vous n'aurez pas ceux qui
travaillent parce qu'ils n'ont pas le
temps les institutions des lobbyings
majeur qui souvent n'a rien à voir avec
leur finalité moi je peux vous dire que
quand j'étais au ministère le seul les
seules structures d'urgence qui existe
dans ce pays pour le soin ce sont les
chu y en a pas d'autre parce que c'est
là qu'il ya du monde c'est là qu'il ya
des techniciens c'est là qu'il ya des
gardes et c'est là qu'on a l'habitude de
faire les choses
moi j'étais au ministère quand j'étais
au ministère au ministère de la santé la
dame qui était en charge de sa voulait
que tous les centres de réception de
risque suspect soit au contraire
extérieur au chu y compris chez les gens
qui n'avaient jamais organisé de calme
donc je pense qu'il faudra arriver à
créer des pôles des infections pôle
regroupant façon transversale et paca
marseille j'avais proposé qu'un des sept
y compris à paris a bien le droit
d'avoir une organisation pour les
maladies infectieuses
si bienveillant et que le pays soit
mallet de noeuds dans lequel il y ait
des docteurs des hippies des biologistes
des scientifiques et de la technologie
pour que nous ne devenons pas un pays de
deuxième zone
dans la lutte contre les maladies
infectieuses
[Applaudissements]